♪♪
-At the end of last week's
"Corrections,"
I asked Shoemaker,
"Is it pencil?"
before I attempted to bite
into the pencil
to prove whether or not it was
a real pencil or a candy pencil.
A lot of you thought
this was in reference
to the television show
"Is It Cake?"
hosted by our friend Mikey Day.
And I was surprised
that all of you referenced
that show, not knowing
that is not the original.
The original host
of "Is It Cake?" was...
First of all,
it aired in the '70s on BBC
and it was hosted
not by Mikey Day
but by British legend
of stage and screen
Alex--
Excuse me.
Sir Laurence Olivier.
We did some digging
and we found a clip
of the popular original version
of "Is It Cake?"
Let's take a look.
-Take your time.
Tell me.
Is it [dubbed voice] cake?
[ Laughter ]
-These jokes, correction jokes
aren't sprints.
[ Laughter ]
In "Roadhouse,"
Patrick Swayze
wasn't a bouncer,
he was a cooler.
This was something his character
made clear many times.
The problem is --
I knew that.
The problem is,
William H. Macy was in a movie,
a different movie in 2003,
called "The Cooler,"
and he's my cooler.
Sorry to say it.
In the order...
I love Swayze, but in
the pecking order of actors,
it is always been, for me --
doesn't have to be
the same for everybody --
Macy, Swayze, Kevin Spacey.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I also love Jake Lacy.
So now top three
could be anywhere,
but it's like Lacy, Macy,
Swayze, Kevin Spacey,
and then...
John Wayne Gacy.
The -- For the serial killing.
Not the painting.
Long story.
Shoemaker is a huge fan of
John Wayne Gacy, the painter.
And so he's very upset
anytime you lump the two.
And he's always walking
around saying,
"I'm sorry that I can separate
the art from the artist!"
And I'm like, "What?"
[ Laughter ]
A lot of you will sometimes
reference and write
about Shoemaker
in the comments section,
and a lot of you guess at
the spelling of his name.
It's not your fault, you know.
Well, actually,
there are credits on the show.
[ Laughter ]
Like I'd say,
maybe you don't have time
to watch the credits, but, uh...
you're leaving comments
in the YouTube section.
Anyways, in case
you want to know,
that is how you spell it.
We also accept that emoji.
[ Laughter ]
Um...
Oh, we did a joke
about "Family Feud"
and we were told we used
an incorrect buzzer sound
for "Family Feud,"
which shocked me.
I could not -- I went back.
I could not hear the difference.
First, let's hear
the real sound effect.
[ Buzzer ]
And now let's hear the one
we used in "A Closer Look."
Then every time they do
another failed roll call,
it can end like this.
-A speaker has not been elected.
-[Deep voice] Buzzzzz!
[ Laughter ]
-Somebody wrote in,
"A GoPro camera is bigger
than a squirrel's head."
Maybe where you live,
but not in New York.
We got some...
jacked squirrels.
Not your, like, Monday
through Friday squirrels.
But in the park
on the weekends
when the bridge-and-tunnel
squirrels come in,
just walking...
[ Laughter ]
[ New Jersey accent ] "I got
your nuts right over here!"
[ Laughter ]
Kevin McCarthy boldly proclaimed
he could count.
We said that wasn't
that impressive
'cause it's a Sesame Street
character skill.
We had him say, "I can count,"
showed a picture of The Count.
"I have a sweet tooth,"
showed a picture
of Cookie Monster.
"Me very ticklish,"
showed a picture of Elmo.
Got it wrong
because Elmo only says "Elmo."
Cookie Monster says "me."
It should have been,
"I can count,
me have sweet tooth,
Kevin very ticklish."
Thank you.
A lot of you wrote that in.
We also said Kevin McCarthy is
second in line
to the presidency,
and a lot of you said
he's third in line.
The thing is, I don't think
President Biden is in line.
You know,
I think he has the job.
Kamala is first in line.
Kevin McCarthy
is second in line.
So, that's maybe
just a difference.
I see where we've split there,
but I do hold fast
to the way we went.
Also, this is interesting.
We do have a succession plan
here at "Late Night," as well.
After me, it's Amber.
And after Amber, it's Scollins.
So if anything happens to me,
Amber takes over.
And if anything happens
to Amber,
arrest Scollins!
[ Laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
I was doing my
Jennifer Coolidge impression.
To great acclaim,
it should be noted.
And I was a little taken aback
by this comment.
"Who's Tanya?
This might not be
an obscure reference,
and if I look it up
and it's simply some
'White Lotus' reference,
then you're writing staff
should be ashamed.
Not all of your audience
is watching 'White Lotus'
or 'Real Housewives'
or whatever show
that reference was from.
If you do not include
the subject of the reference,
you might as well be writing
inside jokes for 'Corrections.'"
And at that,
all I have to say is,
[as Coolidge] Wowwwww.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] The jackal mugs
obviously have been going out.
People are very happy.
Someone thought this was
a nice thing to write.
"I feel like it's important for
everyone to know that sometimes,
occasionally someone breaks
into my apartment building,
opens up everyone's packages
and takes what they want.
My jackal mug had arrived
while I was out of town,
and I received a notification
about another robbery.
I was so sad,
but there was a twist.
The thief opened the box and
then declined to take the mug."
[ Laughter ]
We did a bit about
Benjamin Franklin
trash-talking Thomas Jefferson
during the
Constitutional Convention,
and many of you correctly
pointed out Thomas Jefferson
was not at the Constitutional
Convention because
he was serving as ambassador
to France at the time.
Very embarrassed.
Very embarrassed anytime we make
a historical error.
We try to be accurate
about history
as much as possible
in the body of the show.
It's an unforgivable error,
especially we think about
all the history scholars
who have provided
their scholarship to us.
It would be easy enough
anytime we talk about history
to Google it
and make sure
we get it right.
It was very flippant of us.
It's beneath us.
Clearly, what
I should have said
is Benjamin Franklin
trash-talked Thomas Jefferson
during the Constitution
Convention during a phone call.
[ Laughter ]
We talked about how the Steelers
were eliminated
from the playoffs
after the Jets failed to win.
And we showed a picture of Jets
quarterback Mike White.
And someone pointed out
Mike White didn't actually play
in the Jets game on Sunday.
And all I want
to say to that is,
maybe he [bleep] should have.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sarcastically ]
Oh, no, we got to figure out
what we got here
with Joe Flacco.
[ Laughter ]
I said all dads watch
"Yellowstone."
Someone wrote in and said,
"I'm a father of two
and I've never seen
that show."
Well, bad news, bro --
Those aren't your kids.
[ Laughter ]
We talked about the way
Mike Pence claps.
And first of all,
we said that he should be
holding two coconuts
like he was in
"Monty Python
and the Holy Grail."
Two halves of coconuts.
That was an error.
But, um...
Someone pointed out a really
shocking thing to me.
'Cause I then mimed Mike Pence
running and clapping,
and they said,
"You're clapping wrong.
Mike Pence claps like this."
And I said that couldn't
possibly be right.
And then I went back
and took a look.
Let's see.
What the [bleep] is that?
[ Laughter ]
Look at that again up close.
That was like one of the tests
they did in "Blade Runner."
[ Laughter ]
They were like, "Clap."
If you did this,
that's how they knew.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, we had a headline
about some high schoolers,
a New York Post fake headline.
And one of the high schoolers
was named Keith.
And someone wrote in and said
there are no Gen Z people
named Keith.
So if you're Gen Z
and your name is Keith,
please go -- please go
to @seacaptainpolls,
where we're gonna post the poll,
"Are you Gen Z?
And if so, is your name Keith?"
[ Laughter ]
We talk about our crew
a lot here.
And obviously we had --
our edible pencils were out
and we've been talking about --
the kindness of
the edible pencils
came from the mother of our
sound mixer, Mike Witzer.
And a bunch of you said,
"Are you really saying
you have a sound mixer
named Mike Witzer?"
[ Laughter ]
And I never put it tog--
It does sound like
a children's book.
"Iggy Peck, Architect."
"Rosie Revere, Engineer."
"Mike Witzer, Sound Mixer."
[ Laughter ]
But of course, we know it's not
a family business, right?
Like, his mom's
not a sound mixer.
She's a candy maker.
Of course,
Witzer isn't her maiden name.
I asked Mike what her name
was before she was married.
Mandy Baker.
[ Laughter ]
Ooh, sometimes jackals
really do impress me.
And I'm willing --
I'm always willing to share
when I'm impressed
by a jackal comment.
We told an Amelia Earhart
joke yesterday.
Did not go great
with the audience.
Someone wrote,
"You can't be surprised
when an Amelia Earhart joke
doesn't land."
[ Laughter ]
Someone sent a package
to our P.O. box,
and it was addressed to Wally.
I opened it --
out of kindness.
Because, you know, it was
to Wally, so I assumed
it would be, like,
dog [bleep] or anthrax.
[ Laughter ]
But I forgot, Wally is beloved.
And this is -- it was tiny.
It was in a package, right?
I'm seeing this,
and it was in a bigger package.
I'm like, "Oh, this is gonna be
some bull[bleep] joke," right?
So I unwrapped it.
And, uh...
This is incredible.
Look at that little...
Can you get in close enough?
"Jackals rule."
And a very --
a very believable Wally.
This is art, Shoemaker --
not your clown paintings.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, that's our --
that's our tiny Wally,
and I'm gonna give it to him
as soon as he can prove
it's legally his
if it goes to my P.O. box.
[ Laughter ]
Shoemaker is real, by the way.
Some of you been positing that
he's like a Tyler Durden
from "Fight Club" situation.
[ Laughter ]
Like he's a figment
of my imagination.
Let me tell you how I know it's
not a Tyler Durden situation.
Shoemaker has never walked
into a room and had someone say,
"Whoa, is that Brad Pitt?"
Only...
[ Laughter ]
Different faces.
Exact same body, I should note.
Shoemaker's super jacked.
Thin jacked.
And the amount he has
his shirt off in the office!
[ Laughter ]
Always something.
Loves it.
Loves to flaunt it.
Like, I'll hear like hammering
through our shared wall
and I'll go in and he's, like,
on a chair, shirt off.
Got, like, nails in his mouth
and he's like,
"Got to get the new Gacy up."
[ Laughter ]
We made a joke about...
the scariest thing
someone could send me
is a severed human head.
Turns out I was wrong.
Opened this right before
the show today.
This is not the first time
I'm saying this.
I was right on some accounts
when I said a severed human head
would be the scariest thing
you could receive.
My mistake was the word "human,"
because this came.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm not saying
you owe me an apology,
but you should
apologize to Donna,
who had to run to wardrobe
and get a new pair of pants
after I [bleep]
the ones I was wearing.
[ Laughter ]
Well, you guys...
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Is it Wally?
Is it W--
[ Laughs ]
Not doing this. Bye!
See me next week.